Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je n’aurais jamais dû accepter
cette invitation il y a un an.
Jamais.
Je suis si paresseux que l’idée même
d’avoir un rendez-vous 12 mois plus tard
peut me mener au burn-out.
Et pour tous ceux qui me connaissent -
très peu de gens dans la salle
pour le coup - personnellement,
ils savent que je suis capable de
faire un burn-out sans jamais travailler.
C'est très rare.
Vous avez quelqu’un devant vous
de très rare.
Un feignant absolu.
Quoi qu’il en soit,
plus les jours avançaient,
plus l’échéance maudite arrivait -
nous y sommes -
plus l’événement grossissait dans ma tête,
plus mes nuits étaient gonflées
d’insomnies, plus mon angoisse montait.
À telle enseigne que la semaine dernière,
j’étais persuadé que je devais
me rendre à San Francisco
pour présenter le nouvel iPod, le nouvel
iPhone, devant les cadres d’Apple.
Nu de préférence.
Ce qui rend l'angoisse
un peu plus terrible.
Ceci dit, je suis à La Baule devant vous.
Pas de quoi en faire un plat.
Alors l’existence...
C'est un thème tellement large qu'il nous
évite de pouvoir faire un hors sujet.
Tout est ramené à l'existence.
On l’a vu aujourd’hui,
plein de sujets passionnants
ont été abordés
sous le thème géant de l’existence.
Alors j'ai fouillé un peu.
J’ai travaillé,
puisqu’il m’arrive de travailler parfois.
Et en l’occurrence,
j’ai phosphoré pour savoir
de quelle manière je pouvais
présenter ce talk -
on appelle ça un talk.
Je fais des recherches sur Internet,
j’ai consulté des archives,
j’ai regardé un vieux grimoire,
appelé une voyante
et j’en ai tiré la conclusion
qu’il fallait commencer cette
présentation par une citation.
La citation, c’est vraiment le meilleur
moyen de paraître intelligent
avec le travail d’un autre.
(Rires)
Cette citation doit s'afficher.
Elle est là, elle doit être là pour moi.
« Les romans préexistent quelque part.
Écrire consiste à guetter la proie
avant de ramener l'animal vivant.
Jeune, on croit qu’on crée.
Mûr, on comprend qu’on observe.
Vieux, on sait qu’on obéit. »
Au début, j’ai cru que
c’était du Julien Lepers.
(Rires)
J’ai eu du mal à la comprendre,
ça a duré quelques mois.
Ensuite, j’ai cru que
c’était du Saint-John Perse,
puis finalement, c’est
du Eric-Emmanuel Schmitt.
Mais pourquoi j’ai choisi cette citation ?
Car à mon sens, cette citation résume
à la perfection la trajectoire,
le constat de la vie et
donc de l’existence d’un écrivain.
Si vous le permettez, je vais relire.
« Jeune, on croit qu’on crée. »
Je vais vous emmener en 2013
dans le sud de l'Espagne.
À cette époque-là, j’ai passé
deux ans à écrire un roman
dont aucun éditeur n'a voulu.
Et donc je me suis dit : « Tiens, voilà.
Ça représente beaucoup de travail,
je n’ai pas gagné un centime,
je n’ai qu’à continuer dans cette voie,
ça m’a l’air d’être -
(Rires)
un truc d’avenir assez intéressant.
Comme j’ai enchaîné les échecs
pendant 33 ans,
un an de plus, un an de moins,
il n’y a pas trop de problèmes.
Dans l’avion me menant chez mes parents -
parce qu’à 33 ans,
j’allais chez mes parents ;
c’est un grand signe d’indépendance ;
je suis un grand garçon -
je cherchais le sujet de mon roman.
Le soir même, je ne le trouvais pas.
Et le lendemain matin,
je me mets à ma table de travail.
J’aime bien dire ça,
parce que pour quelqu’un qui ne
travaille jamais, ça donne l’illusion.
Le type qui ne fout rien,
il se dit « table de travail »,
ça va beaucoup mieux.
Et là, j’ai écrit sans y avoir réfléchi,
une première phrase qui est :
« Ceci est mon histoire vraie,
avec des mensonges à l’endroit à l’envers,
puisque la vie, c’est souvent comme ça. »
Tout ce roman, le début en tout cas
de l’écriture de ce roman,
s’est présenté de cette manière-là.
J’ai écrit une bêtise ou une phrase creuse
et j’ai essayé de rendre cette phrase
creuse brillante ou intéressante.
Cette formule de mensonge
à l’endroit, à l’envers,
je ne savais pas du tout d’où elle sortait
et elle me semblait plutôt sympathique.
Ça sonnait bien à l’oreille, ça avait de
la gueule, et ça ne voulait rien dire.
Alors j’ai réfléchi à l’histoire.
Le narrateur est un petit garçon
qui vit dans un appartement immense,
avec des parents extravagants
qui font la fête tout le temps.
Ils dînent à 2 h du matin, ils
petit-déjeunent à 3 h de l’après-midi.
Il y a toujours plein de monde.
Il y a un oiseau très élégant
qui se promène dans le salon.
Et lorsque cet enfant va à l’école,
qu’il raconte sa vie de famille,
ce qui se passe dans son appartement,
personne ne le croit.
En plus, il se fait gourmander
par sa maîtresse - gronder.
Et donc il décide, parce que
c’est un petit garçon intelligent,
de dissimuler tout ce qui se passe
cheznlui et de mentir à l’endroit.
C’est-à-dire qu’il ne se passera que
des choses banales et communes
dans sa vie de famille.
Mais lorsqu’il rentre, sa mère,
qui est quelqu’un d’extravagant,
de très original et qui déteste
la banalité, l’ennui, le commun,
lui refuse le droit de raconter
une journée aussi commune
et pleine d’ennui qu’une journée d’école.
Donc, elle lui impose d’écrire
et de raconter des journées imaginaires.
Donc il ment à l’endroit à l’école
et à l’envers chez lui.
Nous y sommes, j’ai trouvé
de quoi remplir cette formule creuse.
Il s’avère que cette formule creuse
était la première phrase d’un roman
qui a eu la chance de connaître
un grand succès.
Cette formule, qui était creuse au début,
a été lue dans beaucoup de pays,
affichée dans beaucoup
d’articles qui parlaient du livre.
Et donc cette phrase, en somme,
le raisonnement de cette phrase
a changé mon existence.
Ces derniers temps, je me suis mis
à écrire sur les étapes de ma vie
qui m’ont transformé,
en quelque sorte, en écrivain.
Et je suis tombé en creusant
et en fouillant dans ma mémoire
sur deux anecdotes
qui m’ont prouvé quelque chose
dont je n’imaginais même pas l’ampleur.
Et je vais vous les raconter.
Si vous permettez, je vous
emmène en 91, en sixième.
Ma scolarité est déjà un désastre.
Je suis sourd, dyslexique, gaucher.
En somme, je ne comprends rien,
je n’entends rien.
Je fais le contraire
de ce qu’on me dit de faire,
ce qui n’est pas un grand signe
de succès à l’école.
Ça se passait très très mal, mais bon.
En sixième, Monsieur Fleury,
notre professeur de français,
nous demande d'écrire une rédaction.
Cette rédaction a pour thème
les vacances :
« Racontez-nous vos vacances. »
Pour la première fois de ma vie
d’écolier - autant que je m’en souvienne -
j’ai compris ce devoir.
J'ai compris ce qu'on me demandait.
J’avais envie de faire ce devoir
et j’y ai mis du cœur
et j’ai raconté les vacances
que je vais vous raconter là.
Mon grand-père,
qui n’avait rien d’un hippie,
louait chaque année un chalet
dans les alpages, sans eau ni électricité.
Nous allions chercher l'eau à la source.
Nous allions chercher du lait chez les
fermiers d’à-côté, ce qui nous donnait
le sentiment à mes frères et moi
de manger un camembert chocolaté
au petit déjeuner.
Mon frère trayait les chèvres
ma sœur fauchaient les blés
et moi je les regardais travailler
car c’est là ma plus grande qualité.
(Rires)
Sœur Maria Rita, une bonne sœur italienne,
venait du nord de l’Italie
pour garder la chapelle des Vernettes,
qui se trouvait au-dessus du chalet.
Ulysse, un fermier
que nous allions voir régulièrement,
qui avait un sourire édenté,
qui parlait un patois cryptique
et qui se promenait tout le temps
avec son tabouret accroché au bassin,
dînait au cul de ses vaches et en somme,
il prenait ses repas dans la bouse.
Donc c’était un peu surréaliste
pour le petit garçon
qui venait du centre-ville de Nantes.
Quoi qu’il en soit, je raconte tout ça -
vous le constatez, j’ai de la matière.
Ce sont des vacances peu ordinaires ;
je m’applique.
À cette matière, je mets du cœur
et je rends mon devoir.
Soyons honnête,
je n’ai pas remis la main sur ce devoir.
Je suis persuadé
que la syntaxe était aléatoire,
qu’il y avait plein
de fautes d’orthographe
et que c’était un mauvais texte.
Enfin, il n’y a plus de preuve
de ce texte-là.
Mais Monsieur Fleury n’a pas décidé
d’attaquer les fautes d’orthographe.
Il n’a pas décidé d’attaquer la syntaxe
ou les connexions, les transitions,
complètement originales et grotesques.
Il a attaqué la véracité de mes vacances.
Je ne sais pas ce qui lui a pris.
« Ce type a l’air trop heureux.
Il a fait un travail avec le sourire,
il faut que je le ramène à sa réalité. »
Et donc il s'est moqué de moi.
Il a lu des passages,
tout le monde riait, etc.
Il m’a même comparé
à un mauvais mot espagnol.
En somme, Monsieur Fleury m’a humilié.
Moi qui n’avais pas un grand
amour du travail à l’époque,
ça ne m’a pas confirmé dans cette voie-là.
Et -
C’est en somme l’équivalent du mensonge
à l’envers que je viens de vous raconter,
qui a dû sortir de mon esprit.
Je le croyais sorti
de mon imagination sans limites,
mais pas du tout.
Cette anecdote venait de là.
Si vous le permettez,
je vais vous emmener maintenant
encore chez mon grand-père,
mais dans un autre endroit, en Provence,
deux années plus tard.
Évidemment, on voyage tellement
ensemble que le bilan carbone
de mon histoire est déplorable.
Mais en 94, ma situation
ne s’est pas arrangée.
J’ai redoublé ma sixième,
puis comme ce n’était pas assez,
j’ai décidé de redoubler ma cinquième.
Enfin bon, j'étais parti pour redoubler
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours.
C’était encore plus infernal à l’école
et encore plus infernal à la maison.
Donc je vivais 100% d’enfer et il s’avère
que le coin où vivait mon grand-père
était un nid à célébrités.
Il y avait Charles Aznavour qui prenait
des cafés au bistrot du Paradou.
Il y avait la famille de Caroline
de Monaco qui vivait dans le coin.
Michel Drucker y faisait du vélo.
Je pense que Michel Drucker
fait du vélo à peu près partout.
Mais bon, en l’occurrence,
il fait du vélo à cet endroit-là.
Et il y avait surtout Jean Réno.
Jean Réno avait explosé mondialement
avec « le Grand Bleu ».
Il venait d’exploser
tout juste avec « Léon ».
Et je ne sais pas pourquoi,
j’ai fait une obsession.
Je ne sais pas si vous imaginez :
un adolescent très mal dans sa peau.
Peut-être un peu plus que d’autres,
je n’en sais rien.
Mais en tout cas, je fais une obsession :
je voulais absolument voir Jean Réno.
Je voulais de la lumière,
je voulais du rêve,
je voulais de la hauteur,
je voulais l’inaccessible.
À chaque fois que ma famille allait
dans le centre-ville de Maussane,
ils croisaient Jean Réno, chez Charles,
le Boucher, achetant des côtelettes
sur la place du village,
prenant des petits cafés.
À chaque fois que j’allais en ville
avec mes parents, il n’était pas là.
Ils rentraient en disant : « Il était
à la boucherie, à la quincaillerie »,
Jean Réno partout.
Moi, dès que je sors,
il y a Jean Réno nulle part.
Cette incompatibilité d’agenda
me désolait, me rendait un peu triste.
J’avais l’impression
que Jean Réno me fuyait.
Je ne lui avais pourtant rien fait de mal.
Quoi qu’il en soit, les derniers jours,
j’étais tellement frustré,
la rentrée scolaire arrivait, je ne sais
pas, j’ai dû faire une fixette géante.
Cette rentrée me semblait
aussi impressionnante
que de me présenter devant vous ce soir.
Et donc je vais entre Paradou et Maussane
à la recherche de Jean Réno.
Je marche, je marche.
Et là, tout d’un coup, miracle !
Jean Réno me prend en stop.
Le délire.
Non mais, le délire.
(Rires)
Vous n’avez pas l’air de me croire.
C'est agaçant.
C'est la première fois qu'il y a 600
personnes qui me traitent de mythomane.
Enfin, bon.
C'est un problème avec votre conscience.
Quoi qu’il en soit,
Jean Réno me prend en stop.
Je rentre chez moi, j’annonce :
« Jean Réno m’a pris en stop. »
Et tout le monde me croit.
C’est incroyable !
Mon petit frère
et ma petite sœur sont fous.
J'espère même qu'ils sont un peu jaloux.
Ma mère est très heureuse, elle se dit :
« Pour une fois qu’il arrive un truc
sympathique à cet enfant,
ne boudons pas notre plaisir.
Ça n’arrivera peut-être plus.
Ou au moins une fois tous les dix ans. »
Donc elle est très contente,
très très contente.
Et mon père - mon père qui à l’époque,
et ça a duré quelque temps,
concluait toutes mes phrases par « Non. »
C’était un point final
pour chaque phrase : « Non. »
« Il fait beau. - Non. »
« Il est 12 h 30. - Non. »
« Je m’appelle Olivier. - Oui. »
Mon père, qui ne me
croyait jamais, me croit
et en souriant, me demande la marque.
Je lui donne la marque de la voiture.
On m’assaille de questions,
questions auxquelles je réponds
avec un naturel désarmant.
Mon père dit : « C’est incroyable,
cette histoire. C’est extraordinaire ! »
Effectivement, c'est incroyable
car ce n'est pas croyable.
Jean Réno ne m'a jamais pris en stop.
Je ne sais pas ce qui m'a pris.
Je ne sais pas si je mentais
beaucoup à l'époque.
Ce sont des trucs
dont on ne se souvient pas.
Mais bon, là en tout cas,
j’étais frustré de ces deux heures
de recherche sous le soleil.
Et en deux secondes, j'ai décidé
d'inventer un mytho énorme.
Et tout le monde m’a cru.
Et pendant des années, ma mère, quand elle
voyait que j’étais un peu en difficulté :
« Mais Olivier a été pris en stop -
(Rires)
par Jean Réno. »
J'avais les mains moites.
J’étais au bout de la table, « Il faut
peut-être que je lui dise un jour. »
Et je l'ai dit.
La déception !
Tout le monde s’est dit :
« Mais merde, c’est horrible. »
Les gens avaient rêvé grâce à moi.
Vous, vous me voyez venir.
Je raconte lors d’une rédaction
en sixième quelque chose de réel.
Je prends beaucoup de plaisir
et beaucoup de temps à inventer,
à écrire cette histoire qui est vraie.
Et personne ne me croit.
Je me fais humilier par ce prof
comme ça, gratuitement.
Peu importe, j’ai réussi -
dans ce domaine en tout cas.
Et quand j’invente un mytho énorme, tout
le monde me croit, et pendant des années.
« Jeune, on croit qu’on crée. »
Ce mensonge à l’endroit.
j’étais persuadé que ça sortait
de mon esprit très fertile,
de mon imagination débordante, géniale.
« Et vieux, on sait qu’on obéit. »
En réalité, quand j’ai écrit cette phrase
« Les mensonges à l’endroit, à l’envers »,
j’obéissais inconsciemment
et involontairement
à deux anecdotes qui m’étaient
arrivées vingt ans auparavant.
Cette formule a changé ma vie,
en somme, mon existence,
puisque c’est le mot qu’il faut répéter -
Ti ding ! - comme une formule magique.
On gagne 100€ à chaque fois qu’on -
(Rires)
C’est vraiment pratique - Ti ding ! -
Existence.
J’ai eu Delphine, qui organise le TEDx,
il y a trois semaines, un peu inquiète :
« Est-ce qu’il a préparé quelque chose ?
Il m’a l’air un peu gland ce type. »
(Rires)
Je regarde l’heure : 21 minutes.
Oui, c’est carrément gland,
j’ai tout pété là.
(Rires)
Je vais donc finir très très vite.
Elle me dit : « Mais racontez-moi ce que
vous comptez dire à ces braves gens. »
Je lui raconte ça, il y a un grand blanc.
(Rires)
Embarrassant !
Je commence à avoir les mains moites.
« Qu’est-ce que c’est
que cette histoire ? »
Elle a voulu me rassurer,
mais m’a plus inquiété.
Elle m’a dit :
« Mais vous avez un message au moins ? »
(Rires)
« Je n’ai -
Je ne suis pas influenceur,
je ne suis pas gourou.
Je ne suis pas journaliste,
seulement écrivain.
Je n'ai pas de message à faire passer.
On s’en fout de mes messages. »
Mais j’ai réfléchi et je me suis dit :
« Le TEDx, c’est quelque chose
qui doit être inspirant,
inclusif, bienveillant. »
Et donc j’ai décidé
de trouver une conclusion
et de faire passer mon message
qui est le suivant :
« Vive l’humiliation
et vive le mensonge ! »
Car sans ces deux mamelles-là,
je ne serais pas devant vous ce soir
à vous parler de mon existence.
Bonne soirée.
(Applaudissements)